many consider this election to be
turkey's most significant in its recent
history
president erdogan voted in Istanbul
where he began his political carrier
he has reshaped the nation in the last
two decades
his supporters believe he has made it
more powerful Emperor's Paris
one erdog one to win for the sake of
stability for this country
stability and continuity have been the
message throughout erdogan's election
campaign
but after more than two decades in power
he now faces his most difficult
challenge
six opposition parties have joined
forces for this presidential runoff with
opposition leader Kamal kalistarolo
chosen as their unified candidate
he was second in the first round on May
14th
as he came to Cassie's worth in Ankara
he was welcomed by his supporters
they are grown more confident that he
will be turkey as next president
the whole nation wants change because
our country wants its rights Justice and
rule of law
neither president erdogan nor the
opposition leader look who's secured
enough words to win in the first round
it was the high Wars for nationalist
parties that forced the election to the
second round the rise of the Nationalist
parties was the main surprise of the
first round that has forced the
presidential candidates to reconsider
their election strategy to appeal to the
Nationalist Awards in the runoff
the opposition leader kalistaro has
focused his second round campaign on
anti-refugee sentiments promising to
send home millions of Syrian Afghan and
Pakistani refugees syrians will go as
one of the main slogans written on
billboards
as a result the leader of the ultra
nationalist Victory party amid USDA has
announced his support for kalistarovo
but
synonymous presidential candidate who
came third in the first round has
decided to support president erdogan in
the runoff
the preliminary results will be
announced hours after Water cast their
ballots
but this election is closely washed
especially by millions of refugees
facing fear and uncertainty
Al Jazeera Ankara